macarons are one of the most popular but
also most challenging desserts to get
right we spent many months and made
dozens of batches in the pursuit of
trying to find a recipe and some
foolproof techniques to help you do it
right the first time
[Music]
a perfect macaron should be chewy on the
inside and crispy on the outside it
should have those classic feet and a
smooth top
first things first you want to let the
egg whites come to room temperature for
at least 30 minutes before you get
started having the egg whites rest is
going to result in a much fluffier
airier meringue
so pro tip a really easy way to separate
your whites from your yolks is to
actually use your hands you can
alternate between eggshells but you risk
puncturing the egg yolk you could get
some shell in it it's actually a little
more time consuming if you wash your
hands this is a really easy way to go
now we can move on to our dry
ingredients
so you want your dry ingredients to be
really really fine to ensure that smooth
top this is the time to break out your
food processor if you have one so we're
going to add our dry ingredients to a
food processor we'd recommend pulsing it
at least 10 times but you really can't
go too far here the finer the dry
ingredients the smoother your top is
going to be even if you buy extra fine
almond flour it's not going to be that
smooth you might get a bit of a lumpy
surface
if you don't have a food processor fear
not your macarons can still be delicious
they might just be a little lumpier on
top
another tip to get that really smooth
surface is to sift your dry ingredients
a few times after you've pulsed it in
the food processor this is just going to
ensure a really smooth top so you can
get those picture perfect macarons now
we're going to move on to our wet
ingredients start off by beating the egg
whites with a pinch of salt that's just
going to help stabilize them you also
want to use the whisk attachment to help
beat some extra air into your meringue
so you're going to beat the egg whites
just until they get really frothy and
are no longer translucent just like this
that's when you want to start adding the
sugar really gradually if you add too
much sugar at once it's going to deflate
all that beautiful air that you just
whipped into the meringue
once all the sugar is added keep beating
until you get stiff peaks if your peaks
are falling over like this you still
need to keep going
once they're really stiff like this
you're all set so if your peaks are
stiff enough you can actually flip a
bowl upside down without anything
falling out
once your meringue is good to go you're
going to add the vanilla extract you
don't want to do this too early or
you're not going to get those really big
beautiful stiff peaks
and lastly we're going to add our food
coloring
we'd recommend using a gel food coloring
because it gives you a much more vibrant
color using a liquid food coloring is
going to thin your batter out and it's
going to fade during baking
it's really subtle but you can see here
how the one with liquid food coloring
actually looks more peachy than pink
now we're ready to combine the wet and
dry ingredients so first add a third of
the dry ingredients to the meringue now
we're going to macronut that's the
technique of folding the dry ingredients
into the meringue
traditionally you gently fold
ingredients together 35 to 40 times but
we found that you actually want to be
really aggressive to beat out any
remaining air bubbles that'll help you
get a really consistent cookie so
there's not an exact number of times
that you need to fold the batter it's
really just something you want to keep
an eye on ultimately at the end of the
day the texture should look like wet
sand ribbons some people describe it as
lava but how many of us have really seen
lava a tried and true test is to do the
figure eight method one of the biggest
mistakes people make is either
under-mixing or over-mixing their batter
once it's all incorporated go really
slowly and keep practicing that figure
eight until you've got it that'll really
ensure that you don't go too far
once you can make a figure eight with
the batter without it breaking you're
good to go stop here and do not keep
mixing
now that the batter is ready we're ready
to start piping our macarons fill the
piping bag with the round tip put four
dots of the batter in each corner of
your baking sheet then place the
parchment paper on top this is going to
help secure the parchment paper so it's
not going to slide all around as you're
piping a lot of recipes call for
silicone mats but after numerous tests
we found that they can actually make the
cookies a little moist parchment paper
will really dry your macarons out which
is what you want this was one of my
personal biggest revelations during
testing
the classic size of a macron is about an
inch and a half wide you can buy a
template for piping but you can also
just eyeball it like we did
once the macarons are piped it's time to
drop the tray
make sure you do not skip this step
dropping the tray is going to help
eliminate any air bubbles it also is
going to ensure that you get a really
smooth surface on top let the macarons
rest at room temperature for 30 minutes
to an hour the macarons are going to get
this kind of weird film on top and you
can actually brush your finger back and
forth after an hour and see that it's
not going to indent that's the sign that
they're ready to go if you don't do this
step the macros aren't going to rise
properly and you won't get those classic
feet in our case when we tested it the
feet grew outward instead of upward now
you want to bake the macarons at 300
degrees for 17 minutes if you have an
oven thermometer this is a really good
time to use it make sure your oven's not
running too hot or too cold or the
macarons aren't going to come out right
as without baking don't open the oven
door if you do you could deflate the
macarons if your macarons are sticking
to the parchment paper after this it
just means they're a little under baked
you can just pop them back in the oven
for a minute or two when you take the
macarons out of the oven let them cool
in the baking sheet for 15 to 30 minutes
when they're done they should lift right
off the parchment just like this
transfer the macarons to a wire rack to
fully dry out and cool before filling if
you don't all your filling is just going
to melt all over them so while our
macarons dry out we're going to work on
our filling we're gonna go with a really
classic vanilla buttercream and we'll
talk about ways that you can get a
little fancy with your fillings a bit
later on
so first you're gonna cream your room
temperature butter once it's really
beautiful and fluffy just like this
you're gonna sift your powdered sugar
into the bowl you don't have to sift it
but this will just result in a really
smooth creamy buttercream
once everything's combined add the
vanilla
then you can add one or two tablespoons
of heavy cream and mix until it's
incorporated we needed to add a little
more cream and you can just do this a
tablespoon at a time until it's the
right consistency
now that the buttercream is done add it
to a piping bag again fitted with a
round tip filling the cookies is pretty
straightforward just pipe a dollop onto
the cookie that's a little smaller than
the size of the actual cookie then press
two sides together and you're good
now the part that takes the most
patience out of this entire process is
that we'd actually recommend that you
wait at least 24 hours before eating
your macarons this will help them
develop the best flavor and texture you
may be tempted to eat one right away and
you know if you do we won't tell but
really it's worth your while to let them
rest once you feel like you've mastered
the basic macaron feel free to get
creative when you're starting out the
easiest way to customize your macarons
is by playing around with food coloring
and the flavor of your filling you could
flavor your buttercream you can make a
chocolate ganache or a lemon curd the
possibilities are truly endless
and those are the basics of how to get
started making macarons they can be
pretty intimidating and honestly really
easy to mess up if you don't know what
you're doing but if you follow our tried
and true tips you'll be able to master
the techniques needed to nail perfect
macarons every time from here you really
just need to try it how many did you
make
i think i made probably over 2 000
macarons oh my god you know they take a
lot of time
they take patience if you make a macaron
right you've won life
[Music]